non-fiction books all weekend every
weekend
on book tv
from new york university journalist hugh
o'shaughnessy discusses his biography of
former chilean dictator augusto pinochet
mr o'shonas's remarks last about an hour
[Music]
good evening
i'd like to welcome you to the king juan
carlos the first of spain center of new
york university my name is carolyn khan
and i'm the associate director here we
at the center as well as our co-sponsors
at new york university press are very
pleased to have you with us this evening
in particular i'd like to mention that
the consul general of chile is here with
us and we are also fortunate enough to
be
host to joyce horman who will probably
say a few words after the presentation
during the question and answer session
i'd also like to throw in one quick
advertisement before we begin we have
calendars for the center's activities
available in the atrium and we'll be
happy to take names for our mailing list
during the reception following the
evening's reading
it's now my great pleasure to introduce
tonight's speaker
hugh o'shaughnessy is an award-winning
journalist who has been writing about
latin america for close to 40 years
in addition to serving as a regular
correspondent for the economist in the
financial times and writing for a number
of other newspapers and magazines he's
published numerous books on topics as
wide-ranging as the u.s invasion of
grenada the future of south america's
indigenous peoples travels in the
caribbean the role of oil in the region
and prospects for democracy in central
america
as it happens mr o'shaughnessy was in
santiago in september 1973 on the day
that pinochet's troops overthrew the
democratically elected unidad popular
government of salvador allende
having followed events in chile since
that time mr o'shaughnessy published on
october 15 1998 an article in britain's
the guardian warning his compatriots
that a foreign terrorist named augusto
pinochet was in the country
and calling for his arrest
we may never know exactly how mr
o'shaughnessy developed his powers of
foresight but the following day the
world learned that general kinochet had
indeed been arrested in response to the
request of spanish magistrate balthasar
garcon that he stand trial for the
torture and murder of spanish citizens
uh incidentally i would like to mention
that judge garcon will be speaking here
at nyu on april 28th
this groundbreaking situation marks the
first time that a former head of state
was ever detained outside his home
country on charges of crimes against
humanity and its repercussions in
international law already have begun to
be felt both in africa and elsewhere
mr o'shaughnessy's most recent work and
the reason we're here tonight is called
pinochet the politics of torture
this is an incisive work of journalistic
reportage providing both general
information to readers unfamiliar with
chile's dictatorship and new evidence of
crimes by the chilean army during
pinochet's 17 years in power for those
who already have some knowledge of
contemporary chilean history
as many of you may know britain's home
secretary jack straw recently accepted
medical opinions finding pinochet
mentally unfit to stand trial and
allowed him to return home to santiago
related cases against pinochet are
pending in several european nations in
addition international public attention
to this case does suggest the
possibility that pinochet and some 30
high-ranking chilean military officials
may face trial in chile for human rights
violations committed during the
dictatorship in large measure as a
result of the case presented by judge
garcon
if so mr ashanasi's research may prove
extremely important to the case against
the former dictator
after the lecture there will be time for
question and answer mr o'shaughnessy is
fluent in spanish so if you're not
comfortable presenting your question in
english you may feel free to do so in
spanish
books will be on sale in the atrium at
more than a 20 discount and mr
o'shaughnessy will be signing them
please join me in welcoming mr hugh
o'shaughnessy
[Applause]
i think thank you carol for that uh
very nice introduction i'm not going to
take very long um
i start by thanking you uh for being
here
i will just read
a couple of short passages from a book
which uh i
started writing for people in london who
didn't like augusto pinochet but didn't
quite know why they didn't like him uh
and i wanted to
set the record straight so um
i will
read a uh a few paragraphs of this if i
may then
talk briefly about
the life of
augusto pinochet
and perhaps add
a thought or two
about what happened this month and the
departure of the general
from a
royal air force station in lincolnshire
for
santiago and freedom
let's start
three days before the coup which
happened
on the 11th
of september 1973.
at lunchtime on that saturday three days
before the coup
president allende was visited at home by
the newly retired general pratz who
stole who talked to the president
privately
though pratz's diary is silent about the
visit
after their conversation agenda
in grave mood summoned pinochet and
general orlando urbina to a meeting the
next day
at lunch
on sunday at the presidential residence
allende revealed to pinochet that he had
decided to announce the holding of a
plebiscite on the future of the
government allende was convinced that a
majority of the country would back the
elected government despite the political
and economic difficulties into which the
country had been plunged
after lunch with the president pinochet
went home
at about five in the afternoon he and
his wife lucia hosted his daughter
jacqueline's birthday party
an unusual guest arrived in the form the
person of general gustavo lee recently
appointed by allende commander-in-chief
of the chilean air force
lee asked pinochet what he was going to
do
according to lee pinochet was still not
decided pinochet didn't know whether he
was going to join the coup or not
have you thought that this might cost us
our lives in the lives of many others
asked pinochet
while pinochet and lee talked surrounded
by the children's screams of delight
the navy plotters acting without orders
from their commander-in-chief admiral
montero
arrived from valparaiso
they were led by admiral gustavo
carvajal
and they included admiral widovro the
commander of the marines
and captain ariel gonzalez
head of naval intelligence they bore an
important paper from alma jose toribio
merino the chief navy plotter
they too were keen to know which way the
army was going to jump
the paper said the following
9th of september 1973 gustavo and
on my word of honor each day will be the
11th and hr will be
0600
if you cannot carry out this phase with
all the forces you control in santiago
explain this on the back
admiral widobro is authorized to treat
and discuss any matter with you
with greetings of hope and understanding
merino
on the back of the paper were less
formal notes
gustavo this is the last opportunity jt
then
augusto if you don't put all the
strength of santiago from the first
moment we won't be alive to see the
future signed pepe
below that again were the words agreed
was doubly and agreed agust
only the signatures were missing
lee signed straight away
finish a dithered again this is as i say
three days before the coup
uh two days before
if this got out there could be serious
consequences he lamented
lee broke the silence decide general
pull yourself together
agusto pinochet
the pious little boy who always wanted
to be a soldier
signed and under his signature put the
stamp of the commander-in-chief
the way was clear to for lee to send his
hawker hunter fighters the day after
next
to bomb the elected president in his
palace
let's skip forward to
briefly a few years later
pinochet had
escaped formal and personal
excommunication by the catholic church
its ultimate sanction
excommunication would have caused him
great personal difficulty
and might even have put a rapid end to a
dictator who was constantly declaring
his devotion to the the defense of
western christian civilization
he avoided the censure by a hair's
breath
cardinal silva and don silva had been
mulling over the idea of excommunicating
him
the cardinal was later to make a
dreadful a vowel to his close
collaborator enan monty allegri
chile's most prominent human rights
lawyer
in some anguish silva told monty allegri
that there was one particular mission
that he
ralshuva would have to answer for to god
he had never formally
expelled the general from the church
in december 1980 seven bishops from six
seas talca linares valdivia and kuz
te muco and puntarenas issued decrees of
excommunication against all those who
participated in torture incited ordered
or solicited it or being in a position
to halt it did not do so
three years later the bishops conference
that say all the bishops of chile
adopted the decree of the
seven
seas seven bishops
ruling in an agreed document that and i
quote torturers their accomplices and
those who are able to stop torture and
do not do it cannot receive holy
communion nor can they morally be god
parents in the sacraments of the church
unless they sincerely repent
though pinochet
was ex was never excluded
although pinochet was never
excommunicated by name
many in the church believe that his
active promotion in torture and his
unwillingness to absorb it means that de
facto he cannot be seen any longer as a
member of the catholic church
that he was excommunicated is clearly
the opinion of bishop gonzalez or
puntarenas
in his book torture of eucharist dr
william t cavanaugh of the universe of
the university of saint thomas in saint
paul minnesota recounts a conversation
with bishop gonzalez who in reply in
reply to a question from kavanaugh
of whether pinochet had been
excommunicated said yes he is
excommunicated yes yes if he gave orders
to torture you saw the decree if
pinochet is the intellectual author he
is excommunicated if he is not he's not
excommunicated
in september 1982 on his 75th birthday
silva flew to rome and tended his
resignation which the pope accepted
with alacrity
bernice diplomats had maintained a
constant drip of complaint
to rome against silva blaming him for
anything
that they disliked inside or outside his
archdiocese that of santiago the
resignation was announced in may
1983 pinochet's wife lucy explained it
exclaimed
it seems god has heard us
end of quote
let me uh go very briefly into uh
some
uh ideas
that i put out in this book
augusto pinochet i think is
moved by two principal characteristics
he is first of all
a man
who is given
to working very hard
you could say that augusto pinochet was
a workaholic and i think that his uh
his um
um
his career has shown that he is an
extremely hard worker
he is not i think even his best friends
which sadly i'm not one
would uh say that he is not the the most
highly intellectual of people he's
always had difficulty in
in seizing
large concepts
he is a person
not of the first water intellectually
but that he has driven
with great effect to overcome by a
fierce
a fierce a a love of work
binoche
is also a man
who i think is principle characteristic
is one of opportunism
he has not gone through life as a man of
the right
he is not
uh
a man who is hewed
to one particular line
he was born
as some of you will recall in 1915
in the port city of el paraiso to a very
a very pious family his mother in
particular was a very pious woman
and when her young augustus
whose
nickname was tito at that time
when tito fell ill she
lucia made a vow
that if
tito was spared for this life she
herself would
dress in
no garments which weren't of a brown
color
for several years and he wouldn't do so
either and those two very pious uh
uh uh
vows uh to
uh our lady of uh
of mount carmel lebron
were carried out so
the young agusta young tito grew up in a
very
a pious family
he
caught
the eye of um
a
uh
a a very uh young
woman
and
married her
um
she was from a different a different
class social class from him
her father when he married uh her when
he when pinochet married
lucia
was already a senator in the radical
party and was later to become the
minister of the interior injury no mean
accomplishment
he was a member of the radical party
which i might explain here is not
radical in the sense of the radical is
known in this country the radical party
is rather a conservative
party
a party whose members are often made up
of
the
public servants
civil servants
and there is a certain
tinge which is rather anti-pathetic to
the catholic church
and
it is thought i think we can establish
and say say without fear of
contradiction that
augusto pinochet when a young officer
was introduced to the craft of
freemasonry though i don't think he was
a very
great adept of it but i think this is an
early sign
of how this man brought up very in a
very pious christian
household
decided to make the best of what luck or
good fortune had brought him in the form
of his
father-in-law's position
and his father-in-law's views on life
uh later on
and let's uh uh go forward for for a few
years
um
later on uh he
was
uh
a man who caught
the eye of the christian democratic
party
a very powerful party which had many
international connections not least with
this country but also with europe
and whose uh
and which was in power from 1970 to uh
i'm sorry from 1964 to 1970.
pinochet already had a command in the
north of chile a military command
he was
in command of a certain amount of troops
in in northern chile
but he was also given
a certain
he was a
vice he was given the post of uh
almost vice provincial governor
a post which he would not have got had
he not been persona very grata
with the government of the time the
government of president eduardo frey
montalva
the
father of the president who
laid down the cares of office on last
saturday
so
this i think is another indication
of how the very very
hard-working pinochet always had his eye
on the main chance always knew what
opportunities were going and always
did his best to seize them
so i say he went from a
uh
a pious
catholic family to
a relationship with
freemasonry and the radical party
he then made the best of the
opportunities which the christian
democrats offered him
and then um
of course in 1970
um
a government was which was the
government which was elected was a
left-wing uh a government
made up of six very quarrelsome and
almost uncontrollable uh parties and
pinochet who had been close to the
christian democrats
became persona grata with this new
government
it's interesting to speculate about the
following
during the visit to chile of the
then
leader on present leader of
cuba fidel castro
one man was given the job of
keeping
uh
the distinguished cuban visitor
alive and secure and the man who got
that job
was agusto
pinocchio
it is the claim of those close to fidel
castro
that the government of the united states
and i'm not saying this is right but
this is what the the the
cubans say that the government of the
united states launched one of its
several attempts to liquidate fidel
castro
and
during castro's time in
chile
there was a
a an idea that
an attempt would be made on castro's
life
we all know
that
uh
castro left
chile alive he's still alive uh but
it could well be
that the very uh uh um a workaholic
pinochet a man a stickler for for uh uh
the the fine things of life
so put himses back into his job of
of uh keeping uh
the security of uh uh
castro at the front of his mind that he
has saved castro for another few years
in power in havana but
whatever
the
rightness of this the
there is no doubt that augusto pinochet
was given the job of uh assuring the
personal security of phil castro
on the day of
the
coup
tuesday
the 11th of september
1973
as i saw at the time
the
forces
plotting against the government moved
early
there was a first
mandel there was a first announcement of
the coup
signed
by
the four people who decided they would
take control of the four armed forces
that say the army the navy the air force
and the carabineros or uniformed police
those who are with him recall that saul
oriente who had
been
totally convinced of the loyalty of
augusto
was incredulous
at the names of those who were had had
declared against him
and he saw the name of agusto pinochet
and he said
poor pinochet
they've kidnapped him
he did not realize that pinochet
albeit at the last moment after much
vacillation had thrown in his lot with
the other three commanders
and uh
decided to move against
the
legal head of state
so again pinochet
seized
the chances that he had
and i think that little anecdote about
uh
pinochet gives us
a flavor
of
the powers of let's not call it
deception but of fine political judgment
which has allowed him
under many circumstances
always to come out on top
and perhaps supremely this month
when he convinced the home secretary in
london
that he was too ill to stand trial
i won't go
tie you with too many details of
his
finisher's time in power
let me just
share with you some thoughts
about
what has happened since pinochet was
arrested by the metropolitan police
in october
of the year before last
i think that the decision of the home
secretary
to put the metropolitan police and
arrest this man when he was
undergoing
a surgery
um in london
was a decision which
was long delayed
because all those countries all those
governments who had in the previous
years and they come to more than 100
had decided to ratify and put into force
the un convention against torture
were under the obligation
they didn't have the option they were
under the obligation
to seize and arrest
those people who
against whom there was real evidence of
torture this was a decision of the
international community that torture
would no longer
be legitimate in the civilized world
the british government signed and
ratified that agreement
the spanish government signed and
ratified that agreement
uh the first signatory for britain was
the then prime minister
at that time
mrs margaret thatcher now lady thatcher
the signatory before
spain was the government of felipe
gonzalez and of course the signatory in
the late 80s for
the government of chile was the then
head of the state augusto
this
as i say i would like to repeat
put the governments who signed it and
ratified it under the obligation
of arresting those against whom there
was a weight of evidence of torture
now
you will recall perhaps that agusto
peninsula went in and out of london on
various occasions
under
under the governments of the
conservative party and indeed of the
labour party with as they say no letter
hindrance he was not arrested
although he should have been
more than that
the petitions and the applications made
by amnesty international
on various occasions that whenever he
came back the metropolitan police and
the director of public prosecutions the
attorney general uh should arrest this
man that was not done
but nevertheless
uh better late than never uh he was
beneshay was arrested at the end of
october albeit
at the instance of a spanish judge
he was arrested
and there when we then faced a long uh
period when this was hammered out in
immense and indeed wearying detail
through the courts of
london
in the
high court
in the
judicial committee of the house of lords
the highest instance in britain twice
it went back and forth to and through
over over months over more than a year
as you all know um
and the
decision
uh
that this man should not have immunity
was reiterated
it was said twice by the the house of
lords
by doing that the house of lords
set
in my view an international precedent
which is perhaps second only to the
precedent set by those who ran the
nuremberg trials for those
uh responsible for some of the crimes of
the second world war but it set a
precedent
which has given those who might think
that they were in danger of being
arrested
when they went abroad pause
it has
led to the fact that the dictator of the
central african state of chad
who was seen as a
bulwark of western values in the middle
of africa and but who wasn't who was
again a
tin pot dictator and who was a man who
who indulged himself in torture
has been brought to trial in the
republic of senegal and is facing is
facing action legal action as we sit
here
this the decision taken
to arrest pinochet i think is one of the
major decisions of the end of the 20th
century for the international community
it is to me
a source of some disappointment i will
put it no higher
that
uh the home secretary jack straw
has decided
how can i put it has decided to be
hoodwinked
by this man
who is a master of woodwinking
uh it is for me a matter of uh
some disappointment
[Music]
that uh
this
man who against whom there is
overwhelming evidence of gross
violations of human rights on a massive
scale
was sent back was allowed to go back to
chile
uh
ill though he might have been the the
the journey back to chile is a lot
longer than the two-hour journey from
london to madrid
and i'm
really sorry that uh
jack straw um
did not follow through
as i've said before perhaps drop the
ball in
in terms
of uh
sports uh
sporting metaphors dropped the ball
and allowed this man
to escape justice it would have been
much better in my view
had this man
been allowed to
have been told to go to spain where the
spanish authorities the spanish judicial
authorities who grew up could made their
mind up
about the evidence uh about his own
mental and physical disabilities um it
was a pity i think that
jack straw
tried to keep the evidence secret
and i'm afraid
it was foreseeable that the four
countries who were seeking peninsula's
extradition namely spain
france switzerland and
belgium
have all
put a large question marks
over the validity of the evidence which
was presented to and accepted by jack
straw that i think is
is a pity
but nevertheless let us give uh
the government
which jack straws serves some marks out
of 10 for
for having arrested him in the first
place i don't want to say any more than
that
if there are any questions as carol said
i'd be very happy to try and answer them
and then i think there's some lovely
wine waiting for us outside isn't there
i'm looking forward to that okay
yes
forgive me yes uh
if you could wait for the mic to get to
you then
everybody would be happy
um
obviously the word torture is uh is in
your title of the book and uh
there's no question i guess that a lot
of torture had actually taken place
while financially was in was in power
um i have i guess a twofold question
especially in light of the piece that
you're in first of all
how direct is the evidence that he
personally
was uh responsible for it other than you
know by being the head of state when all
these things happened
and also the way he described pinochet
in you know in his early years and you
know in the days leading to the coup
where he didn't seem to even be all that
involved and he wasn't filled with
hatred for the communists i could see
how it was a natural step to jail people
or exile them
but or even shoot them if as an extreme
example but why would he torture people
i mean that seems like a an extreme way
of acting towards someone who he didn't
seem to care for you know barely a few
days ago well uh as far as the question
of the torture is concerned
there is no doubt there is sickening
evidence sickening evidence of the
amount of torture
and the methods of torture
which were
thrust on the defenses or defenseless
people within chile during those times
i have some details in here
we
are gathered here
in a friendly group there are people
listening to us from outside and i don't
want to go into the details but some of
the details not all of them are in this
book which i've decided not to read out
this evening
was
pinochet
conscious
of what he did
uh
his
chief of police
general contreras
certainly said that he was
contreras was a man
who was
second only in
authority
in chile to
punish himself
contreras said
i did nothing which was not
um
ordered from me by
the head of state
nor did i do things which were not
ordered by the head of state
there was a there's a very uh well-known
uh quotation from general pinochet
which goes
not a leaf moves in this country
except i move it
which is a quite a big claim quite a bit
slightly poetic perhaps but nevertheless
quite quite wide
every morning not every morning but
regularly many times a week
the chief of police the dina as it was
known in the first years
went to pinochet's residence and had
breakfast there to discuss the
agenda of the day
um the two men communed at that meal
contreras went in pinochet's car
to punish his headquarters and there was
constant touch between those two men
contreras was the man who ran the
torture centers ran the
centers of detention there can be
absolutely
no doubt
from
the evidence not least of
contreras himself who
is
in jail uh i mean very comfortable
german nevertheless in jail in chile
that he received orders from the head of
state there can be absolutely no doubt
that finisher was involved
in an intimate level
in what i can all
only say are bestialities
um basically i have two questions one is
um given the fact that
as it's my understanding that a general
was extradited to um italy
um
a couple of days ago
is that it or no uh i don't think so i
mean the the the uh
the italians are
uh the italian government is very hot on
the pinochet case they've had uh members
of their society
killed by this man and tortured by this
man
i
i have not heard and i've been
away from my own home for a couple of
days now i don't think
that that has happened but certainly the
the the italian government is keen that
justice be done in this case
um well aside from that would you care
to speculate um
what could happen now in chile
um first of all do you think it's likely
that anything will happen
why or why not and also um
what could happen to fidel castro given
the president that's been said
uh there are others in this uh room who
are much
from whom you've got a much more expert
view about what will happen
than you get for me but you've asked me
and so i'll reply
pinochet at the moment
is covered by
uh to some extent by an amnesty he gave
himself
he is also covered
by
a
parliamentary immunity
which he acquired
when he gave himself again
the title of senator for life
that
uh parliamentary immunity can be lifted
and there are uh uh
there are acts going on in chile
uh which
would tend to try and lift that immunity
i don't know and i say there are many
people
in this hall with us who know more about
the possibilities than this but there
are
there are
attempts going on to lift this immunity
were that lifted
his parliamentary immunity
it is the view of many people
that
pinochet who still
has a honorary relationship with the
armed forces of his country he is still
captain general
a title
a title of honor some people would say
gives him
the
possibility of saying i'm not going to
be judged in a civilian court i'm going
to be judged by a military court
um
i think it would be a brave
soldier a brave officer
who
uh
sat in judgment about his captain
general and found him guilty
don't think it will happen
in addition to that
you have
the
action taken by
the last government that of president
eduardo frey ristagli who
put down the burdens of office as you
know on
saturday last
who has been pushing through an
amendment to the constitution
to produce another
type of chilean another rank of chilean
a a rank of chilean who has been
a former president of the republic
according to
what my
friends say who know more about
chilean
legalism than i do
there is no machinery at all
to lift the immunity of a former
president of the republic
i may be wrong there but i think
pinochet is very well protected
there's a belt and there's a brace
there um
he is he is
a very uh a very
well protected individual within his own
country
but there are always
the
new possibilities
some of us were very heartened
to hear
of
the action of a very senior person in
the
uh
in the hierarchy in the in the
constitutional hierarchy of chile
a woman called
clarosh jalansky
who is the head of the committee for the
defense of the republic a very senior
a part of the
chilean
governing mechanism
um who has uh taken on herself to put
the weight of her office
in
the
case of
the caravan of death
a
particularly nasty piece of murder which
happened very shortly after the coup
and who
has in the past
shown
uh a great deal of interest in more the
senior side of what happened during the
dictatorship in chile
notably
and i talk about it a little in this
book um the
rise in the trade in narcotics drugs
in chile during the dictatorship so
we don't know i think it's
i wouldn't bet my money and i would
be
reluctant to bet your money on on on a
pinochet facing trial
but he might
um this morning in a program in national
public radio you mentioned that in your
opinion the chilean government was uh
motivated by nationalistic reasons to
attempt to bring back penetration yes
and that's a very
delicate
adjective to say nationalistic reasons
could you elaborate a little bit more
and also
would you consider
feasible
other
uh
alternative reasons
yes you remind me that um i didn't reply
to
a you on the question of of castro
um
i think
that there can be no other reason than
nationalism
for a government
which signed a convention
itself accepting international
jurisdiction on the question of torture
and the sort of abuses of human rights
which are very firmly alleged against
benefit
the chilean government is under a duty
as is indeed the government of spain as
indeed this is the government of the
united kingdom and a hundred other
governments more
to seize these sort of people wherever
they can be found
this is not itself a very new concept of
universal jurisdiction against people
who've committed particularly horrible
crimes
in the 18th century
there wasn't terrorism such as we know
it today
but there was a great deal of piracy
and wherever a pirate
could be found he could be brought to
justice by whatever
machinery there was to bring these
people to justice that is why you've
seen
all around the atlantic and all around
the pacific oceans gibbets and
places where people
who were convicted of piracy
were
hanged and executed because piracy was
seen as a violation of
universal norms
today
thank god they're not so many pirates
about at least
on the waters there's some
on the land but nevertheless
on the water there are there are not
many around
but the idea of a universal jurisdiction
for people who have so offended so
basically offended as
to
involve themselves deeply in torture
and deeply uh
in gross violations of human rights
persists and that is uh
what commits those signatories of that
document to pursue torturers
pinochet himself signed the document
it's not somebody else it's not a
civilian government it's not some
mealy-mouthed people who couldn't or not
strong enough to wear a military uniform
he himself
signed
the
uh
commitment of the republic of chile to
the
universal uh
fight against
torture
and if he signed it he should stand by
it
i think that
the british government should have stood
by it before they did but at least uh
better late than never they did they did
a a a stand by it and it's only i think
a misplaced nationalism if i may say so
which has uh
allowed
the chileans to pretend
that it was wrong for pinochet to stand
trial either in london
or in madrid you raised the question of
fidel castro i think that anybody who
stands
accused of gross violations
on uh defensible grounds should
face
the consequences
we cannot have one law for the powerful
and another law for the rich we can't
have an international uh
law for
uh commerce and trade and not for
uh
the rights of human beings so
i think it should be um you know it
should be extended to whomever uh
is shown
with good evidence to have been accused
of of gross violations
i think we're uh getting near our time
i'm certainly keen for some of that
chili and wine
that's waiting for us but perhaps joyce
would you like to say a word
may i say i'm how delighted i am that
you're here with us tonight i'm very
very grateful for you to be here
for being here tonight too
i was in santiago in 1973 in the coup my
late husband charles was killed by
pinochet forces
the story was told in the movie missing
uh which is a 1982 movie which perhaps
some of you saw
uh in that movie
our experience was reflected very
accurately which was
that there was a lot of circumstantial
evidence that the u.s military personnel
that my husband encountered in vina del
mar
uh a few days after the coup
were
very enthusiastic and taking a lot of
credit for the success of the coup
and it looks uh very much like they may
have given the nod to the chilean
military forces uh
some somehow looked the other way when
my husband was executed by them
so
one of the things that i
truly uh regret of pinochet not being
put on trial in spain is
to have been able to ask uh to have had
lawyers ask him about
u.s support certainly um we know that he
was looking for u.s uh recognition
at about the same time that my husband
was killed and it doesn't seem that a
logical thing to conclude that the
chilean military would
kill an american at that particular time
without some nod from the americans so
the clinton administration is actually
clinton has asked for the chilean or the
documents release
on chilean human rights
situation or slightly before the coup
and after the coup
and so many of the u.s agencies have
been going through and reviewing their
documents the state department has been
pretty good and in fact last october
in the second round of release of
documents we found that a document that
had been redacted 20 years ago
was unredacted in a paragraph that said
the state department felt there was
circumstantial evidence that the u.s
intelligence agencies played an
unfortunate role in the death of my
husband
so
this is what we thought 20 years ago
turns out the state department thought
the same thing but didn't tell us about
it
until last october
now there is a third round of documents
released which is due in june
and the cia and the defense intelligence
agencies are under the same obligation
as the state department to review and
release as many documents as possible
they have not released any so far and
june is the last opportunity they will
have to release these documents
so i am asking anyone here who wishes to
write to their congressperson or senator
or madeleine albright or the head of the
defense intelligence agencies or the
head of the cia tenant or clinton or
anyone that you want to write to and say
please insist in the
to the intelligence agencies that they
review and release all documents
i have found out just in following this
process that
the
cia and the other intelligence agencies
have what they call operating documents
which they don't even consider
documents to be reviewed for release so
i think that uh the american
citizenry is not being served by this
policy and that there really has to be a
push from everybody
requesting that these documents be
released and fully unredacted which
means no
no information blocked out
and so that's what if anybody is moved
to write any letters i would ask you to
ask
them to see to
and to to be sure and pressure the cia
and the defense intelligence agencies to
release all documents about this period
of time in chile because the u.s is the
repository of most of the information of
what went on
during the coup
and they were there to help
help overthrow democratically elected
government and to help
consolidate the power of a brutal
dictatorship of pinochet
so
please ask your
representatives and senators to release
to have these documents released and uh
thank you very much thank you
um
can i j
before we end formally um just add one
thing
people like me who want to see punisher
on trial and do not want him
sentenced to death because i am
dead against the death penalty in
whatever country it
is
the norm
we don't particularly want him
imprisoned he's 84.
what we want is just a word from a judge
to decide
whether this man
is guilty
or
innocent
i don't think that any judge
of any caliber who reviews the the the
papers will find
anything but a guilty verdict but what
those of us who want a trial to take
place
are after is some sort of
symbolic finding of this man guilty for
the
deeds which i believe he's done thank
you very much
[Applause]
hugh o'shaughnessy is a journalist and
broadcaster who's covered latin america
for nearly 40 years he was in santiago
on the day of pinochet's coup d'etat in
1973.
pinochet the politics of torture is
published by new york university press
[Music]